i think we may have to go on conspiracy
social club where we talk about
conspiracies
i think we have to jump over to a
different platform like rockfin
because then leave patreon well because
vimeo if you talk
sam was talking about he was disparaging
this is [ __ ] so crazy
this is like weird sam was not going to
[ __ ] a bar show by talking about this
are you
no all right sam is disparaging a
political figure
okay who andrew cuomo okay and
we got kicked off that that we got
kicked off vimeo
because you can't spread misinformation
i debunked the conspiracies right so he
comes up with a conspiracy and
yeah he brings it to the bunker right
and what's he saying about andrew and
his brother
well he was he was taking an extreme
view on
on when andrew cuomo sent covet positive
patience back to the nursing home old
folks got it
to flatten the curve what i was saying
is that he wasn't trying to murder
people but he was trying it was a
political thing
he looked good managing correct and it
wasn't in his interest to have a bunch
of people died well no he's gonna want
to vote he's getting recalled now yeah
like why would he want
he's gonna lose his job right his his
approval ratings but sam had a different
take on it
and meaning that that he's a sociopath
and all that oh and when you do that
vimeo goes you are you're talking
conspiracy
but that's an opinion that's the show
yeah that's not that's something
we got taken but but people can't watch
flip conspiracy social club so i gotta
go over to
at all no they took if you're if you're
talking conspiracy
so video right vimeo has a thing where
you can't talk conspiracy even though
i'm
debunking it vimeo it said you cannot
someone reach out to him go you know the
show is
one guy spits conspiracies the other guy
argues against them doesn't matter
that's what he tries to do that but what
they do is they just say you violated
the
terms and patrons on venmo so yeah so if
you are on patreon they use vimeo as
their video people like to watch their
podcasts
yeah so now do you know that we got to
go over here i signed up for it
yeah i did the whole thing now now like
i don't know i don't know i didn't know
about them yeah that would have been me
a censoring i didn't know that yeah i
didn't know i don't know that so patreon
this must be a new thing right
because behind the paywall doesn't
matter bubba it doesn't matter they have
their policy
that's that's insane but but this is
what we're having freedom of speech it
doesn't exist
you you have so as long as the narrative
fits whatever they believe in
you can do this new york times what's
her name uh uh stacy abrams i think
she tweeted she just tweeted that the
democrats um
wrote a letter demanding what uh
demanding what comcast a t all these
huge cares are gonna do about fox
news's spread of misinformation
what about the left that's that's that's
their narrative both of them are foolish
there's been so we're dealing now with
with the
power structures idea of what
misinformation is
what they deem yeah conspiracy and so if
you
say you cannot say you cannot say
if you better if you're on youtube right
you cannot say that masks
don't work if you say i don't think
masters are effective
you are you are in youtube we're not
saying that yeah we're not saying that
i'm not saying that i'm sorry but if you
mentioned what we just did you hear what
we all just did
yeah we all just went we're not saying
that yeah in america well you know uh
i it was either on kingston or this i
said we were roasting somebody
and i said you look like a proud and you
know they pulled the entire video there
you go really for the proud
reference so all triple he said was he's
a sociopath well
tripoli well okay to be
goes crazy with conspiracy yeah that's
what's saying
i'm not a conspiracy theorist i just
think a lot of them are are actually
destructive i don't i don't agree with
them and i know a lot of people do
but for me i think it's important to
push back on conspiracies because a lot
of these conspiracy theories and i'm not
talking about sam here
sam's one of the nicest best people i
know great but a lot of conspiracy
theories whether people know it or not
have their roots in old school
anti-semitism
it goes back to the nazi era it just
does yeah i mean
say what you will but at the end of the
day when you start talking about the
rothschilds and all these bankers
they're all jewish bankers you're
what you're doing is spreading you know
and i also am pro
i believe in vaccines i study a little
history and when you
have these massive it is a problem when
you have like
russian and chinese you know elements
trying to spread disinformation about
vaccines and then you get
there a lot of people are very
distrustful it works so
i i i understand that big tech has a lot
of issues the
the worry for big tech is that when you
do have real misinformation and it
starts
gaining traction and it can get people
killed
like it did in with the rohingya and
different countries
yeah you watch the social dilemma that's
a real [ __ ] problem yeah
that's a real problem but that
misinformation it also did with covert
right like some people didn't take you
serious at all
ended up dying but a lot of doctors a
lot of the doctors who were saying
look we're on the front lines the stats
you're hearing
are not consistent with the stats we are
seeing the stats we are seeing are lower
they got pulled but but here's what i'm
pulled for but here's what else
you know cnn won't let the brothers
interview each other
they he he's prevented he they won't
allow him to interview his brother about
any of this
personally i like seeing those guys talk
and i and i know i knew chris
i like seeing them too i liked chris
chris i believe chris cuomo like
he gets a lot of flack for being a
liberal if chris cuomo was
from my experience and and also know
people are still in touch with him
if chris was here hanging out or we were
out you he's a
he's a guy he's not a he's a he's a very
reasonable thoughtful guy he's not
he's full of [ __ ] on cnn though but so
so is the fox guys
yeah to me it's almost a character
because they have to they
they have to because they get paid they
can't tell they get told what to say
their ratings depend on their echo
of course they just read off the monitor
yeah and then they put their input in
and he's obviously
you know far left so these [ __ ]
don't even necessarily believe it
um not all there's no way they believe
all of it i think that you'd you know i
think someone
but i think the to to back to them
pulling like what's fake news and all
that and they don't want miss
uh information spreading i think the
media and especially the news
i don't know how it is in the rest of
the country but especially here in la
like
i know for and cdc cdc's gonna release
this so they're saying oh you know
there's the brazilian strain there's the
african strain
it's much more deadly the cdc came out
went that's their
that's what that's their take on it yeah
we gave them this information where
yeah it might be more uh contagious but
it's not
nowhere near as deadly that's not true
but the noose takes it to scare you well
the
world health organization also drives a
lot of cdc said was like
no no you guys took what we sent you one
way and you're running with it yeah so
here's
the okay so then what yeah what's your
guys's sources of
you know where do you get yeah where do
you get your news then
it's not fox and cnn you you can be if
you listen to
fox and cnn you can do that and you can
you can listen to it with a grain of
salt and just
understand that depending on who you're
listening to on those news organizations
that they are as much opinion makers
their opinion they're they're so so they
have an agenda they have an agenda
they're speaking to a to their echo
chamber so tucker carlson's speaking to
people that already agree
with him and already have a preconceived
they doubled down the world championship
yeah and they
died on that hill yeah and then so laura
ingram that's the angle now if you go
over
you know to cnn or cn um rachel maddow
she's going to be speaking to people who
have who lean
left but they're also so see that's what
makes it but cnn's like
here fox is here and then you can listen
to both and come here
yeah like the beast
yeah there's a lot of like that some
news organizations try to be
super neutral about things but you have
to always listen to how they're phrasing
things because it's very hard
you know i'm telling you i'm not i guess
i'm about to release this this uh did i
tell you about this i'm about to release
this this interview tomorrow with a guy
named aleister bostwick yep
aleister bostwick i sent you that thing
on he said he had that youtube thing on
what crystalia should have done
yeah and he also has another thing on on
information we could have used yesterday
and he also has a video on on the truth
about woody allen and
and his documentary you can see that no
but you got to see what no
he's a real journalist alistair bostwick
is a real journalist
okay and he went and looked at all the
stuff like with mia
and like you know what really happened
three of her three of her 11 children
uh three of her 10 adopted children
committed suicide um
there was there was apparently and he
has the courtroom transcripts
they offered willie allen eight if he
gave
them eight million dollars um you know
to shut to to they would shut up they
wouldn't make it a scene and woody allen
was like no
i'm taking a lie detector and she
wouldn't take a lot
watch the video but anyway i did an
interview with him i'm going to release
it tomorrow i don't know what i'm going
to release
on but yeah yeah i said what you're
going to release but i said yeah because
i do want to watch it oh it's great
i'll release it on youtube okay based on
my channel whatever yeah and i'll i'll
post it on i'll just search brian yeah
i'll post it on my instagram i got you i
know we're fine so he's a
he's a lib he worked for liberal
corporation he worked for
um he worked for uh buzzfeed he worked
for
huffington post now he works for verizon
okay and he's
essentially a freelance guy but he's
really
he just tries to just he's a [ __ ]
thorough journalist and i said
if i were to say to you um if you were
to say
look you you're at the huffington post
very very liberal and
very anti-trump right and if you were to
say
let me find one good thing about trump
like let me find one good thing that
might have been good for the economy
let's say
his deregulation policy and he said it
would get greenlit
however however would it be promoted
would it be on the front page no right
and then what would happen to me
when i come back to work the next day
and the week after
are you going to want to come to work
every day and have people cutting their
eyes at you all the time
like that yeah and then they start
talking about you on the chat boards
like they did to uh barry what's her
name barry weiss in new york times yeah
super liberal but she was like this is
getting crazy guys this is an ideology
and we're not even reporting the news
objectively
they started talking about the chat
board it got so hostile for her that she
had something
so what did he do well he said what
happens in the situation
what happens is you go over to you over
you go over to breitbart or the daily
wire because you can't
you don't know yeah so you so we get so
journalists get pushed
in one team or another you just you
can't help but get pushed in one
direction or another otherwise you're a
pariah at your own work
that's a problem so i i anyway it was a
good interview because he's he's
somebody i respected he's a young guy
yeah we found him because of the chris
stuff right yeah you and i were saying
that to each other yeah
i'm like for sure sending this watch
woody allen thing he did [ __ ] yeah
but yeah but that's what makes it tough
because like yeah like i mean
i never watched the [ __ ] news based
off of like just like you said like
fox is over here you know it's seeing it
it's just i don't know it's just such a
wild
world and then like to pick a side you
know i don't know it's just it's just
two what side is brian williams on the
11th hour which side with that
williams is pretty he's just pretty
vanilla yeah he makes a lot of money
because he's not threatening
not threatening but would you have to
take a side to far left before right
it's like brian he's jesus because
that's why he for me or
no i'm just saying like for brian
williams yeah out of all the guys i
mean yeah oh so this is vanilla ice
cream yeah okay
i mean i think also to keep in mind like
you know it's like are you left are you
right or wrong
give me the give me the issue give me
the topic immigration yeah
i don't know it's really complicated i
don't want to see kids in cages
i know that we all agree with that but
at the same time i don't think we should
have every
i think borders are reasonable and they
mean something if they don't then then
take the front door off your house you
gotta have some regular i mean so so
how do we do it it's not easy when latin
america is a disaster when you've got
guatemala el salvador
and you've got desperate people coming
and you're you're a border agent
and you're dealing with children who've
been in the desert and they're
dehydrated or maybe dying
and you're dealing with all this [ __ ]
and you're finding people who are dead
that shit's all you're doing is you're
not even political at that point you're
just trying to make the world a better
place you're just trying to deal with
all the [ __ ]
you see you're part of an organization
called ice people saying you're bad
well bro i'm just i'm just trying to i'm
trying i have a job to do i'm trying to
you know it's really the incentive
structure that causes people to other
behavior but also with that with like
immigration stuff like
the the rules are almost for the the
exception so it's like when we're in
syria when all the syrians left
and germany was like yeah we'll take
them it's tough because you're going to
get those those outliers those guys who
are still involved in iceland
it can't just be that easy as well
france goes we'll take them and then
they have all these issues
yeah but again those guys are the
exception majority of the people that
come over they're going to contribute to
society
and be good people yeah but the that
exception will scare
everybody and keep them out you get like
young man it's like it's
it's like it's like you know like real
italians [ __ ] hate the godfather
goodfellas yeah because it paints all
like you mean italian
mafia yeah like that's how my grandpa is
0.01
of italians are in the mafia they
[ __ ] hate it dude
so same with like muslims like oh isis
are you kidding me dude
you mean muslims are in the world you
know me and isis 0.0001
but did they get labeled yes
i think 10 of our medical uh doctors and
staff
are muslim in this country you know if
you're iranian
or you're you know from that you know
you come here or whatever and you're
muslim
you go to school your parents are like
oh you're going to be a doctor or a
lawyer you've got a couple choices yeah
yeah you've got to get six degrees
yeah this is the same thing you know how
many italian irish
what's that you're italian irish italian
irish that's why i have that's why i
[ __ ] i
grew up all over the world right yeah i
did repeat let me play real quick how
about that
when i get off stage at the laugh
actually right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this wrote a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son